last year for the first time ever more
fentanyl than heroin
was stopped at the border and now in
focus texas republican congressman chip
roy
congressman you had warned us that this
day was coming where every single state
in america would be basically a border
state unified by illegal drugs
yeah harris well happy new year good to
be on your show thanks for focusing on
this issue when so many people refuse to
and thanks to bill for being one of the
few people who willing to go down to the
border do the job of the media to
actually shine a light on what's
happening to the american people to
texans to ranchers to migrants while aoc
is hanging out in miami sipping
cocktails hypocritically without a mask
on uh you know complaining about
policies where is she going down the
border as she was a couple of years ago
in a white pantsuit by a channeling
fence you know crying and gesturing next
to a fence where is she crying over the
51 dead migrants when that van
had an accident a week or two ago
because of the danger that's going on
the cartels moving people the human
smuggling that bill just reported on
human smuggling that's occurring in the
district i represent in san antonio
where people are being moved up i-35 in
the corridor there where's the vice
president where is my orcas where is the
president they don't care this isn't
about failed policies this is about a
purposeful dereliction of duty a
purposeful refusal to execute the laws
and you have uh more crossings in the
last three months of last fiscal year
than more than twice as many as when
president trump was there we had i think
almost half a million apprehensions that
we know of in the last quarter of 2021
this is shaping up the worst year ever
and so we need to actually change our
policies that's why i've introduced the
title 42 discharge petition and my
colleagues have introduced a migrant
protection protocol discharge petition
of course not a single democrat has
joined it wow i i want to lean in more
on that when we get together again uh
just to just to unpack a little bit what
you said
um you know the numbers that you're
throwing out are so huge but what they
don't take into account
is just how much stuff is moving let's
pop it up if we can customs and border
protection seized more than 11 000
pounds of fentanyl during the 2021
fiscal year surpassing the amount of
heroin that was captured for the first
time ever
and congressman roy where i want to go
with this obviously that the sheer mass
of it is is eye-popping this is such a
danger to our law enforcement because of
the high potency just a few seconds your
response
well we saw we know 13 border patrol
agents have lost their lives we've got
dps having to fill the gap from texas
down on the border they're in danger and
while the president is going around
preening and yelling at the american
people trying to force ineffective
vaccine mandates let's focus on the
hundred thousand dead americans from
opioid overdoses and fentanyl pouring
into our communities if you're watching
this show ladies and gentlemen in your
schools in your community is fentanyl
coming in from mexico coming from china
through the cartels we need to do
something about it don't let this
administration get away with it i will
bring you back we'll go deeper thank you
congressman hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now